hello everyone and welcome to a game or
rather a video where i will tell you
something about the candidates the
candidates tournament and we're gonna
check out a few games between the
candidates they have played uh so far
against each other yeah so it's the 13th
of june that the candidates tournament
starts on the 16th of june that's
actually my birthday so you know it's
always nice when things work out but the
first game of the candidates will start
on the 17th of june now who are the
candidates and where is it being played
the candidates tournament is being
played in barcelona in spain and it will
be played in palace of santona if i'm
pronouncing that right you can see it
right here it is absolutely beautiful
uh i mean i can't even imagine playing
chess in in such a place um i mean look
we can just marvel at it and uh so i i
really like the
venue that fide has chosen for uh for
this grand event as it is the greatest
tournament uh that um you know there
ever was and will be it is the
tournament where the winner will get a
chance to face uh the world champion
magnus carlsen for the title of world
classical champion and usually it's okay
to be second in eternity it's okay to be
third but here in the candidates
tournament it really really stings if
you get uh second place like in in the
candidates tournament you don't really
care if you're second or last uh
uh only the the first place really
matters and uh of course everyone will
uh will fight for it so if you if you
are from spain or even better from
barcelona you can check it out i'm sure
it will be open for viewers i don't know
maybe they will be uh maybe they will
charge some tickets maybe not but um
you know it would be it would definitely
be a great place to meet the one of the
candidates or maybe even all of them you
know maybe get a photo with them maybe
get an autograph um
if you guys are interested in that so
that's uh the venue and these are the
candidates so as you can see uh the
candidates are ding lyran uh there is a
fire fabiana karwana
and of course if you guys are interested
in how all of them qualified uh nepo of
course yanni pomnichi qualified by being
the runner-up of the world championship
2021 he played the world church
championship match against magnus
carlsen uh he lost but he gets an
automatic ticket to the next candidates
tournament then you have rajabov who
qualified for the previous candidate
tournament but he dropped out he didn't
want to play due to the covet breakout
and uh fide has awarded him sort of uh
he he's nominated by fide uh to get a
direct um uh entrance into the next
candidates tournament because nbl took
his place in the previous one uh then
you have young sister of duda uh the top
one of the top two finishers of the
chess world cup 2021 second one being
sergey karyakin but he was disqualified
and ding leeron uh takes karakin's place
um uh as a replacement as as he had the
highest rating in classical just for may
2022
uh that was the the criteria if you guys
remember ding had to play like i think
it's 34 games maybe it's 32 or something
to
just simply because he didn't have
enough classical games to to actually
qualify for the event then you have the
two top finishers uh in the feed a grand
swiss tournament of 2021 that's alireza
furuji and fabiano caruana
alireza being the winner and fabiano
being the runner-up and the two top
finishers of the fide grand prix 2022 uh
being rihard rapport and hikaru nakamura
so it would be uh well of course it it
it is going to be absolutely enjoyable
regardless of who wins the candidates
tournament but magnus still
uh hasn't made it absolutely clear if he
will play
uh should anyone just win the tournament
because for for now i believe the
information is that he is willing to
play alireza if all it is a place then
magnus
will be interested in facing i i think
it's because he represents the next
generation he's the young one he's the
one that you know really really fights
hard he he who wants to be the best he
wants to
be the next bobby fischer or you know i
know that he is one of his
greatest role models uh so i think
magnus would be motivated to play
against him but it's very very hard to
imagine that magnus would actually drop
out of the world chess championship
cycle and uh not play ding for example
uh because who who wouldn't uh think
ding to be a
worthy opponent but yeah i can um i see
where he's going with this alireza is
young and he thinks that that would be
uh definitely a match to promote uh but
uh i don't know yeah i think uh for
example if if nakamura wins the
candidates tournament because of his
huge online following uh i i think that
would be the the most followed event uh
not just in chess but in you know
of all the sports perhaps i mean it
would be such a spectacle but the i know
uh in any any match would be absolutely
uh uh absolutely thrilling to watch uh
so that's pretty much it for the uh me
to the candidates if you if you guys
have any questions be sure to ask in the
comments i will try to address them and
also if you have a game that was played
between the candidates that you would
like to
you know would like everyone to see do
use hashtag suggestions suggest the game
and i will try to uh show it before the
actual start of the candidates
tournament now this is the uh this one
game i chose it's from the tall memorial
the seventh tom memorial in 20 in 2012
10 years ago
uh and uh it's a game between taymor jaw
and hikaru nakamura so uh it's the the
first one that we're showing and it's uh
it just has a really really powerful
final move of the game so i i thought
you guys might enjoy this one and it's a
blizzard game so we're not going to
overanalyze that i already spent quite a
lot of time
you know telling you about the venue and
the candidates and so on uh so let's
dive straight into it uh rajabov has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 hikaru
goes for the dutch defense he plays f5
we have c4 knight to f6 and now knight
to c3 we have d6 and now knight to f3 uh
pawn to g6 and now queen to c2 so this
is all very very standard stuff bishop
to g7 with bishop to g5 and now knight
beat the d7 and this position has been
reached up until that point in 20 2012
but here after uh our job of h4 it's a
new move so all now already as of move
seven uh we have a completely completely
new game so let's see how high replies
he just castles we have pawn to e3 and
now queen to e8
uh getting away from that uh from this
diagonal and uh preparing to push e5 the
queen will be very useful here
but as the queen now left the defense of
the c7 pawn our java just plays knight
to b5 and it's a not the most precise
way bro the most precise is actually h5
because the
the queen's the absence of the d8 square
allows h5 because this is not
problematic for black problem is if you
play knight captures on h5 which of
course is possible now you allow knight
to d5 because there's no knight here and
now this point is saying in this pawn is
saying plus you've also just gave white
in a semi-open h file this will be very
very close to winning for white but okay
it's a blitz game like i've said knight
to b5 going after the weakness of c7
queen to d8 hikaru says all right i've
made a blunder or not a blender i've
made a slight mistake we have to first
defend the pawn then kick away the
knight and then move the queen back to
e8 so okay i i've wasted a move so rajab
of castles queen side we have c6 and
knight back to c3 and hikaru goes back
queen to e8
we have c5 now uh putting pressure on
the center and now we have pawn to d5
hikaru closes the center we have bishop
to f4 uh and now ponte b6 attacking the
overextended c5 pawn we have c captures
on b6 a captures on b6 and now knight to
e5 offering a trade of knights and
bishop to b7 he carries also very happy
here he now gets the
the semi-open a file to use for attack
and if he can start pushing those queen
side pawns he might be able to attack
the white king and here we have bishop
to e2
uh we have knight to e4 uh sorry putting
pressure on the on the knight here as it
is a valiant defender of white's queen
side knight captures an e4f captures and
now ponte a3 as our a2 pawn was hanging
there knight captures an e5 d captures
an e5 and now pawn to h6 and hikaru says
i'm i'm very happy here i'm now ready to
start attacking on the queen side so f3
rajab wants to open up lines in the
center captures will allow him to open
up the d file c5 by hikaru he starts
advancing the queen side pawns with f
captures on e4 d captures an e4 the
bishop would still guard the e4 pawn and
but now bishop the c4 would check we
have king to h8 and now bishop to e6
here rajab wins the d7 square and rook
the d7 is coming so this will be very
unpleasant for hikaru and you don't
really get anything with uh rook d8
because we'll just trade one pair of
rooks and then we'll play rook to d1
attack the queen and then rook to d7 so
here bishop c6 just stopping rook to d7
uh and now king to b1
uh always uh a nice prophet prophylactic
idea except when it isn't
queen to b8 now ready to start pushing
those queen side pawns and now bishop to
d5 uh with bishop captures rook
countries now uh rajab ready to double
up on the d file queen to b7 attacking
the rook here and the rook h to d1 we
have queen to c6 uh now the c pawn
will be defended we have to defend it
one more time if we want to start
pushing the b pawn but also we can just
start pushing the c pawn so rook to d7
our java just continues with his idea of
putting the rook on the seventh rank we
all know how powerful a rook on the
seventh can be they call it a pig for a
reason it just gobbles up everything
and here you should play a move that is
uh queen to e6 but it's very hard to
understand why until you see rajabov's
next move so here rook f38 was played
instead
putting a rook here to defend the pawn
on e7
but this actually blunders the game for
hikaru so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only winning move
for a job of while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
f7 square is free for grabbing and for
those who just want to enjoy the show of
course the movie is queen to c4 uh to
all of you who found this you have just
defeated one of the candidates of the
next candidates tournament
but for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show that's the move queen to
c4 are moved 29 and he was in this
position on move 29 that hikaru nakamura
resigned the game uh as there is nothing
more to be done here so what you've done
with this move of course you want to
grab hold of the f7 square if your queen
gets here then everything sorry about
that then everything just falls apart uh
but the move that black had to play and
now you of course understand it if
you've spotted queen to c4 uh it's just
a blog prevent this queen to e6 prevents
queen c4 and now you are ready to start
pushing pushing that pawn you could play
c4 right away but the queen to e6 is
more precise so here after rook to f8 of
course queen to c4 and you resign
there's absolutely nothing you can do
because let's say you play e6 to prevent
queen to f7 it's not a problem
whatsoever because now you've given up
control of the d6 square now the other
rule comes to d6 and that's it you can
play queen a4
we happily trade and we're just up too
much material rook captures on b6 and
this is of course now completely winning
for black whatever you whatever move you
make
we just win the seventh rank completely
now we have two pigs here and that's it
now we're gonna capture the bishop if
you defend it it doesn't really matter
bishop captures an h6 you can't capture
because of checkmate and uh well that
that's just it so another thing you
could do after queen to c4 is say okay
why not just continue attacking is queen
to f7 really that bad uh it is it's it's
devastating queen to f7 now we're gonna
play b4 now uh it's black is also
attacking uh but still rook one to d6
there's just no stopping this move now
you can't capture because of checkmate
the rook and queen will be going after
the the bishop on g7 and the once the
queen moves we're just going to play
bishop captures on h6 absolutely
everything is winning here let's say i
mean bishop captures nh6 is the only
winning move
but uh after captures um
you know it's uh
now everything is winning rook captures
on g6 and there is no defense this will
be checkmate if you move the bishop
somewhere uh to the
remove is from from the defense of the
g7 square then queen the g7 will be
checkmate if you play brush up here then
the rook no longer guards the g8 square
then rook or queen to g8 will be
checkmate so like i said everything will
end in checkmate here and another thing
that could be considered is maybe just
the rook of fate we guard the df7 square
but now the seven pawn hangs rook
captures on e7 you have a past e pawn
and there's no playing this let's say b5
we see we play queen d5 there are there
are better moves here but queen d5 is uh
good enough we trade captures captures
and the white is just uh
completely winning here so of course
hikaru knows this after queen to c4 he
resigned and a wonderful wonderful
victory for uh temura japo i actually
wanted to show you the first game
between the two of them that they have
ever played uh it's actually from 2008
but the only uh
trace of this game on chessgames.com
uh
the moves are completely scrambled and
it feels like they are rated eleven
hundred the moves they're making make
absolutely no sense so i i don't think
that's the game they played so if i ever
find it i will show it as it uh you know
it kind of looked like uh like a good a
good game before they started making
silly moves but you know i i i really
doubt that's the game uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it ended
this little bit of extra info about the
candidates about the venue where it will
be played in in madrid in spain uh and
also uh the candidates uh themselves uh
so yeah i hope you enjoyed that then
like i said use hashtag suggestion in
the comments if you have a nice game
between the candidates i will gladly
show it so we can prepare properly for
the candidates tournament that starts on
june 16th or rather june 17 june 16th is
the
opening day and june 17th will be the
first game played uh so yeah once again
i hope you guys enjoyed everything um
regarding all of this i would like to
thank adrian martin nagorski david
kaiser uh tyler single clark uh benjamin
bogweld and martin georg paparik for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions regarding the
candidates uh and you know whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day